zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
corona ist noch nicht ganz überwunden da
macht ein neues virus von sich reden es
geht um die affen pocken weltweit auch
in deutschland gibt es erste infizierte
und die frage stellt sich natürlich
bekommen wir es da jetzt mit einer neuen
pandemie zu tun wie gefährlich ist
dieses virus für uns menschen dazu
werden sich gleich unter anderem der
bundesgesundheitsminister und auch
lka-präsident wieder äußern und wir
haben die gelegenheit vorher schon und
auch nach dieser pressekonferenz mit
einem fachmann zu sprechen nämlich mit
professor dr clemens wenger er ist
infektiologe und chefarzt an der münchen
klinik schwabing und jetzt bei uns einen
schönen guten tag herr professor wendler
hallo susi wimmer nach grüner sind viele
menschen für viren besonders
sensibilisiert wie groß schätzen sie
aktuell die bedrohungslage für uns
menschen auch hier in deutschland ein
also muss ganz klar sagen das ist keine
signifikante bedrohung für die
normalbevölkerung in deutschland es wird
keine neue pandemie daraus erwachsen wir
haben ein sehr begrenztes
infektionsgeschehen und es ist quasi
jetzt die gunst der stunde
das auch so begrenzt zu halten und denke
ich dafür ist heute auch tpk mit einer
hand lauterbach entscheidend gut also
erstmal ein bisschen deeskalierend das
ist ja vermutlich auch kein schlechter
ratgeber in dieser zeit eure fragen und
kommentare wie immer gerne an uns über
die kommentarspalten oder eben auch über
die übliche adresse und bevor wir mit
professor rentner weiter sprechen wollen
uns noch mal einen kurzen überblick
verschaffen über die aktuelle lage zu
den affen brocken und auch zum
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland er
hat das affen pockenvirus in deutschland
erstmals nachgewiesen wo man wölfe vom
institut für mikrobiologie der
bundeswehr bekannt sind zwei
virusvarianten die zentralafrikanische
linie die macht bei zehn bis elf prozent
der menschen einen schweren manchmal
sogar tödlichen verlauf die
westafrikanische variante ist noch
einmal deutlich bilder da gibt es eine
sterblichkeit von 1 prozent etwa es ist
diese variante die bei allen fällen in
europa auch bei dem patienten in münchen
aufgetreten ist die symptome sind immer
gleich fieber kopf- muskel- und
rückenschmerzen geschwollene lymphknoten
und schließlich hautausschlag mit
bläschen und pusteln schon mit den
ersten symptomen kann man ansteckend
sein der 26 jährige patientin münchen
ist zwar noch in der klinik aber dem
patienten geht es weiterhin sehr gute
hat jetzt keine allgemein symptome mehr
kein fieber mehr keine schluckstörung
mehr angesteckt haben dürfte es sich auf
partys oft trifft es menschen mit vielen
wechselnden sexualkontakten affen pocken
brauch ne
übertragen sich nicht wie saskia virus 2
durch feine aerosolen über große
strecken sondern eben nur über kurze
distanz durch größere tröpfchen oder
eben durch die hautveränderung und
können sowohl über die bläschen als auch
dann am ende wenn die kosten noch da
sind diese bläschen abheilen diese
infektion übertragen eigentlich sind
affen pocken eine viruserkrankung bei
tieren die nur gelegentlich infektionen
beim menschen auslösen und das meist nur
in einigen regionen afrikas nun häufen
sich die fälle weltweit die gefahr einer
massenausbreitung sehen experten dennoch
nicht der mensch ist ein viel wird für
diese brocken das heißt die fühlen sich
eigentlich nicht so wohl menschen und
dementsprechend machen sie meistens auch
nur milde krankheitssymptome zudem
bietet die klassische pockenimpfung die
es in der bundesrepublik bis mitte der
1970 er in der ddr bis anfang der 80er
jahre gab einen gewissen schutz und die
bundesregierung denkt für risikogruppen
über zusätzliche maßnahmen nach
spezifisch für die affen brocken also
herstellt es sind auch so
überlegungen im gange wie eine
eventuelle also impfung dann aus der
stattfinden wurde aber neben der
allgemeinen bevölkerung ist hier nicht
im gespräch wichtig sei nun die fälle
aufspüren
isolieren und analysieren keine panik
aber doch vorsicht
ja keine panik aber doch vorsicht
professor wenn ja was würden sie denn
den menschen aktuell für
verhaltensweisen empfehlen wir haben
auch gerade schon das stichwort
impfungen gehört was es dazu zu sagen
ja also es ist so dass die impfung nicht
für die allgemeinbevölkerung
vorgesehen ist und angedacht ist
es geht eher
begrenzte
personengruppen
die sich das ist ja auch schon noch
nicht diskutiert worden war in
körperlichen kontakt nicht jetzt auch
bei sexualkontakt infiziert haben da
sollte jeder überlegen ob er solche
gefährlichen kontakte gehabt hat und
wenn er dann hautveränderung feststellt
dann ist das gut sagt und wo man zum
arzt geht aber wie gesagt es ist jetzt
erst mal keine warnung für die
allgemeinbevölkerung hier wie sieht es
denn mit der impfung überhaupt
allgemeine aus das ist ja eine
erkrankung die pocken zumindest die ja
bei uns schon seit jahrzehnten als
ausgerottet gelten könnte man sich da
jetzt überhaupt impfen lassen
prinzipiell ist so dass es auch in
deutschland
impfstoff gibt allerdings der ersten
zweiten generation also wenn sie möchten
einen veralteten impfstoff es gibt einen
sogenannten dritten generation sync
stoff einen modernen impfstoffe basieren
auf einem abgeschwächten pockenvirus wir
nennen das auch
im schiff also modified sexy cora im
stoff dieser impfstoff afrika ist
zugelassen seit 20 13 in der eu also
auch in deutschland allerdings ist er
nicht in einer öffentlichen apotheke
verfügbar
das heißt da ist jetzt gerade
laufen verhandlungen dass man
entsprechende kontingente auch für
deutschland verfügbar macht fragen wir
nochmal spezifisch nach wikinger will
will wissen über youtube von uns muss
man sich jetzt noch mal impfen wenn man
eine impfung schon mal hatte also
offensichtlich vielleicht ein zuschauer
der schon älter ist der sich vielleicht
damals schon hat impfen lassen
ist es so dass die klassische bauten
schutzimpfung wie sie ja von 1980
eigentlich durchgeführt wurde
ausreichend gut auch gegenüber acht
wochen schützt das heißt hier ist also
keine impfung empfohlen lediglich für
personen also älteren jahrgangs also
40plus sage ich mal das ist ja dann die
personengruppe die geimpft wurde früher
wenn eine immunsuppression dazu kommt
also zum beispiel eine krebserkrankung
eine herzerkrankung solche sachen dann
wäre der impfstatus aufzufrischen nach
jetzigen bisschen
würde dann allerdings eine einmalige
gabe auch des modernen impfstoffes
reichen wenn man die grundimmunisierung
vor 1980 erhalten hat 1 kommentar der
uns erreicht über youtube von schreib
soll endlich die nächste panikwelle also
da möchte ich mich im namen auch unserer
redaktion da möchte man es von
distanzieren also um panikmache geht es
gar nicht wir wollen ja mit ihnen eben
genau das gegenteil erreichen wir wollen
ja sachlich sprechen über die aktuelle
situation und wie man sich dort am
besten verhält von panik ist hier noch
überhaupt keine rede jetzt haben gerade
gehört das ist für übertragungen anders
als bei corona engen körperkontakt
braucht aber aus der kölner zeit wissen
wir auch wiederum dass sich ja auch
viren verändern können dass die
mutationen bilden könnte also irgendwann
der fall eintreten dass die übertragung
dann leichter erfolgt ähnlich wie bei
corona dann doch über die luft
beispielsweise
also dafür haben wir momentan definitiv
keinen anlass in diese richtung zu
spekulieren
auch die bisherigen analysen auch
außerhalb von deutschland wird ja
sequenziert in england in spanien etc
gäben keinen hinweis dass sozusagen das
affen wochen virus von seinem genom
verändert wäre natürlich wird das weiter
verfolgt werden aber wie wir das von
corona erkennen diese varianten
diskussion die haben wir haben wir noch
gar nicht also die infektion die wir
bisher beobachten sind jedoch wenn sie
möchten risiko kontakt zustande gekommen
und betreffen ja auch noch relativ wenig
also in europa sprechen wir hier um
circa 100 bestätige oder circa 100
bestätigte fälle
gut dass dazu jetzt vielleicht gerade
noch mal die nachfrage ja genau wie kann
es sein dass das virus sich gerade jetzt
in verschiedenen ländern ausbreitet ist
ja auch ganz interessant werden ihren
beitrag für ein auch gehört der mensch
sei eigentlich ein viel wird für dieses
virus also wie kommt es dazu dass es
gerade jetzt dann doch zumindest
vermehrt fälle da gibt eben menschen
betroffen sind
also schauen die betroffenen sind hier
sozusagen menschen
jüngere menschen das heißt personen die
eben nicht über die grundimmunisierung
was die punkte angeht verfügen in der
regel sind all die betroffenen nach 1980
geboren
und das zweite faktor ist dass wir
insbesondere einen infektionsgeschehen
haben im bereich von männern die mit
männern
sex haben also in der msm community das
heißt jedoch dieses enge kontakt
verhalten offensichtlich beobachtet
gewesen es gibt erste hinweise dass auch
sozusagen mögliche infektionsquellen
entsprechende sage ich mal massenpartys
waren stichwort maspalomas preis etc
weil das wird von den
gesundheitsbehörden natürlich sehr eng
noch nachverfolgt werden aber das
könnten gewisse erklärungsmuster seien
für den jetzt beobachteten ausbruch
insbesondere in südeuropa aber immer
auch mit wenigen fällen in deutschland
viele machen sich natürlich auch
gedanken was die jüngeren mitbürger
achten geht also sprich die kinder weil
eben auch zu lesen ist dass in afrika da
eine höhere sterblichkeit besteht gerade
bei den jüngeren die situation lässt
sich aber auf europa und deutschland
glaube ich so nicht direkt übertragen
wie sind ihre einschätzungen dazu
absolut
richtig wenn man da sollte man auch
wirklich entwarnen und keine panik
verbreiten
da hat er auch für eltern und natürlich
auch die kinder sollten keine angst
haben es gibt historische daten aus
afrika das statistisch betrachtet die
auf dem brocken bei kindern unter 16
jahren hätten zum teil einen schweren
verlauf haben dazu sage ich aber ganz
klar die kindersterblichkeit ist leider
auch in afrika unabhängig von affen
wochen sehr hoch das heißt wir haben
auch mangelernährte kinder in afrika das
heißt die daten sollte man bitte nicht
auf europa nicht auf deutschland
übertragen und heute morgen das fand ich
auch sehr gut hatten die kinder hast du
noch mal sehr klar auch and waren sich
das hier also kein grösseres risiko für
kinder besteht ja das ist einigermaßen
beruhigend vielleicht auch noch mal hier
eine nachfrage aus unserem publikum
fabian korinth sie sind vorhin schon
kurz darauf eingegangen er will wissen
welches sind denn nach aktuellem
kenntnisstand die hochrisikogruppen
sind
zunächst mal alle personen die einen
sehr engen
körperkontakt haben
sexuellen kontakt muss man hier explizit
nennen der ungeschützte abläuft wir
haben offensichtlich in kürze
infektionsketten bei männern die sex mit
männern haben aber wir sagen dazu es ist
natürlich auch insgesamt eine priorität
ein risikofaktor als risikofaktor zu
benennen und sonst darüber hinaus müssen
wir sagen haben wir halt nicht keine
risikogruppe natürlich wenn diese enge
körperkontakt in verbindung steht mit
einer immunsuppression denken sie dann
an
erkrankungen wie
hiv/aids oder auch charakters erkrankung
dann kann das natürlich noch mal das
risiko für in den einzelnen höhen
gut wir gucken immer mit einem auge auch
auf die pressekonferenz zu der ja gleich
der bundesgesundheitsminister erwartet
wird der lka-chef und auch der
ärztepräsident klaus reinhardt wir sehen
allerdings das kann ich ihnen zumindest
verraten die das publikum noch keine
akteure sondern ich sehe momentan nur
stuhlreihen und da ist also noch nichts
im gange sobald sich da was tut gehen
wir natürlich dann live rüber herr
professor wenn er vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz zu den symptomen also wann
sollte ich mich zum arzt begeben was ist
typischerweise sozusagen der staat bei
einer solchen infektion mit affen
brocken wie sieht das aus genau also der
staat ist in der regel bricht und
spektakulär die betroffenen haben zu
beginn oft ein wenig fieber
muskelschmerzen können hinzukommen
es kann dann in der folge auch leichte
lymphknotenschwellungen auftreten und
dann in der zweiten folge treten eben
auch hautveränderungen auf das sind
diese typischen sage ich mal packen
artigen veränderungen dazu muss man
wissen auch die brocken entwickeln sich
über mehrere stadien am anfang sind sehr
hautveränderungen sogenannte makula wie
wir sagen dann entstehende aus pappeln
also die sind sozusagen mit einem
kleinen dann erhabenheit verbunden auch
was das niveau angeht sie stechen hervor
und dann werden diese bläschen mit
flüssigkeit gefüllt so genannten risiken
und dann erscheint sich um von weißlich
so ein bisschen der einheit erinnern das
nennen wir dann das puzzle stadium und
zum schluss entsteht eine koste die dann
ab das ist sozusagen das was wir was wir
sehen waren und es beginnt oft im
gesicht aber es gibt auch ausnahmen
davon wir haben also unser patient hat
im gesicht wenig es kann auch irgendwo
an den beinen oder am rücken ein wie
immer das sind sozusagen die typischen
veränderungen die dann auch die
patientin zur ärztin zum arzt ok also
das heißt wann würden sie raten zum arzt
zu gehen konkret nach welchen symptomen
was ich glaube wichtig wäre schon dass
man schaut
hobbys hautveränderungen gibt das ist
hier entscheidend ich glaube es wäre
eine überforderung auch der ärzte wenn
jetzt jeder mit kopfschmerzen oder
fieber sofort zum arzt rennt das können
ja auch ganz banale andere infektionen
seien die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es
dann ja vier wochen sind die es hier
insgesamt sehr gering in deutschland
verstehe bei uns im chat wird auch über
windpocken diskutiert zumindest dem
namen nach könnte es da einen
zusammenhang geben aber danach wird dann
eben auch gefragt gibt es den und die
frage lautet dann auch wenn man keine
windpocken hatte ist dann ein schwerer
krankheitsverlauf zu erwarten
zunächst zu den vips es gibt klinisch
einen klaren unterschied die eben
beschriebenen hautveränderungen laufen
bei den windpocken quasi
versetzt habe dh sie könnten platzen
haben der hat in einer körperstelle
die sehr frühen marco dej und an anderen
stellen die pusteln man nennt das auch
ein buntes bild oder einen sternenhimmel
bei den klassischen harten brocken sind
die hautveränderungen synchronisiert das
heißt der patient hat überall am körper
am anfang eben dieses jahr früh makula
stadion später eben das kostenlose
stadium das ist für uns ärzte schon ein
großer unterschied
windpocken und sozusagen verlauf acht
wochen die zweite frage da ist noch ein
was wir bisher wissen kein zusammenhang
also wenn einer keine windpocken hatte
heißt es nicht dass er ein höheres
risiko für affen pocken hätte oder gar
hier schwer kranken würde gut also wir
warten immer noch auf die
pressekonferenz sehen dort aber noch
nichts wie gesagt sobald sich was tut
gehen war über fragen wir doch
vielleicht gerade einfach noch mal ein
bisschen zur historie dieser krankheit
also ursprünglich von tier zu tier jetzt
offenbar von tier zu mensch mensch zu
mensch wie ist da die
entstehungsgeschichte vielleicht können
sie das uns noch mal kurz erklären
ja also der der namenhaften pocken diese
ein wenig irritierend
entstand eigentlich
1958 als das erstmalig waffen gesehen
wurden wurde aber nie wie kam es dazu
die affen infizieren sich quasi auch
über
nagetiere also experimente sekrete von
nagetieren ist natürliche reservoir also
die natürliche wird für die affen pochen
sind eben nicht die affen das hatte er
professor für korrekt gesagt dass er ein
viel wird sondern sind nagetiere also
eichhörnchen etc
und die überlegung ist das in afrika
haben zum teil auch ein sehr enger
kontakt besteht
natürlich auch durch jenische
verhältnisse das eben auch nagetiere im
menschlichen
räumen
in kontakt haben und dann eben solche
infektionen überspringen können wir
kennen aus nigeria jedes jahr gewisse
infektionen aber wie sie richtig sagte
er wer man ist gab es jetzt geben dass
das besondere die übertragung menschen
zum nicken schätzt man sie sommer ja die
übertragung mensch zu mensch die
natürlich tendenziell eher so ein
bisschen beunruhigend ist aber sie
hatten ja vorhin auch schon gesagt
momentan noch kein anlass zur panik und
wir hoffen es bleibt auch so denn die
übertragungs zahlen sind wir in der tat
noch sehr gering und auch die
infektionswege offenbar so geartet dass
es da also jetzt momentan nicht zu einer
pandemie zu kommen droht ich lese gerade
hier noch mal geschaut zumindest nach
bei uns im chat
wenn man sich mit jemandem christ
bekommt man dann auch die pocken fragt
tamara wie ja nun also die frage ist
natürlich berechtigt das hängt natürlich
davon ab wen man küsst nämlich mal stark
wenige vielleicht haben sie
aber ernsthaft noch mal also die
übertragungswege sind in der tat so dass
man über küssen tatsächlich sich
anstecken könnte
ganz genau das sollte man noch mal kurz
festhalten also eine tröpfcheninfektion
ist prinzipiell möglich warfen brocken
aber
glaube ich ganz wichtig noch mal zu
betonen auch in abgrenzung zu corona
eine übertragung eben überall aerosolen
also über die luft was wir erkennen von
corona das ist nahezu ausgeschlossen
beachten brocken also das ist nicht das
risiko sondern eben der direkte kontakt
üblicherweise eben auch über die haut
lesung die pocken recht und wenn einer
selbst sozusagen auch eine offene haut
hat weil er eine hauterkrankung hat ein
ekzem zum beispiel dann ist er natürlich
gefährdet wenn er keinen bock
infizierten in kontakt hat dass er über
diese offene hautstellen auch die pocken
herein trägt also augen auf der wahl der
partner auch für solche vielleicht
vorübergehenden erfahrungen da sollte
man also noch mal gucken ob da
irgendwelche auf ja nein nein ich mache
jetzt hier um passende witze das sollte
man nicht tun der frage gibt es affen
trocken wie die gürtelrose auch ohne
haut erscheinungen in seltenen fällen
wird uns über facebook die frage
gestellt
also das würde zumindest nicht die
klassischen definitions kriterien von
hafen pocken erfüllen wie der name ja
sagt hier gehört eigentlich die
hautläsionen obligat dazu man muss eher
umgekehrt fragen gibt es patienten mit
affen pocken erkrankungen die vielleicht
auch die affen bock einsatz die haut in
sich tragen
dass da haben wir erst hinweise auch von
unseren patientinnen das sozusagen die
affen pockenviren auch im blut kursieren
können praktisch spannende frage was
sozusagen mit anderen
körperflüssigkeiten
sekret in der zentral ist wie hoch dort
die viruslast ist er dran dann auch noch
eine weitere frage über facebook von
christa faßbender wir hatten die
schluckimpfung und die influenza-
bekommen reicht das
das sind sozusagen impfungen die
natürlich nicht gegen
affen pocken schützen wenn man sozusagen
den garantierten schutz gegen pocken
oder harten brocken haben heute nein das
sind zwei andere impfung verstehe also
dann hat das damit eigentlich erst mal
nichts zu tun die affen trocken sind ja
auch in anderen europäischen ländern zu
beobachten belgien hat bereits eine 21
tägige quarantäne für infizierte mit dem
virus eingeführt und in großbritannien
wurden bislang die meisten fälle gezählt
dass wir uns gerade auch noch mal
anschauen
in großbritannien hat sich die zahl der
fälle innerhalb kürzester zeit mehr als
verdoppelt und liegt stand gestern abend
bei 57 entsprechend wurden verschiedene
maßnahmen zur eindämmung getroffen denn
dieser ausbruch der krankheit
unterscheidet sich von vorherigen
gelegentlichem auftreten in einer
hinsicht wesentlich
wir haben in europa in den letzten fünf
jahren ein paar fälle bei reisenden
beobachtet dies ist das erste mal dass
wir fälle in mehreren ländern bei
personen vermelden die nicht in die
endemischen region in afrika gereist
sind
eine pockenimpfung kann helfen
entsprechend hat die britische regierung
mehr impfstoff angekauft in
krankenhäusern in denen sexual
krankheiten behandelt werden wurde
personal bereits geimpft
unsere maßnahmen werden sich im
wesentlichen darauf konzentrieren fälle
früh zu erkennen die kontakte dieser
person zu identifizieren und dann eine
sogenannte ring impfung durchzuführen
das heißt so viele dieser
kontaktpersonen impfen wie möglich
zusätzlich müssen sich alle
identifizierten engen kontaktpersonen
für 21 tage in quarantäne begeben
konkret jeder der mit einer infizierten
person in einem haushalt lebt oder
sexuellen kontakt hatte
so und das also die erkenntnisse aus
großbritannien dazu ist die situation
dort mit unserer hier vergleichbar ich
meine im prinzip ist das ja so vom
allgemeinen standard ähnlich
absoluter so groß mit einer art jetzt
numerisch ein paar fälle mehr als 20 da
gibt ja noch ein paar meldungen die wir
erwarten aber
und gestern abend waren es in
deutschland sechs bestätigte fälle mal
sehen was der heutige tag so bringt aber
wie sie richtig sagen die situation ist
vergleichbar von daher kann man dann
auch trefflich über die zu treffenden
maßnahmen wie sie großbritannien schon
durchgeführt hat wir haben gerade von
der ring impfung
gehört auch diskutieren können sie das
noch mal kurz erklären ring impfung was
bedeutet das ja dh
das ist eine
impfung
man sagt auch regel oder regelungs
impfung oder informations impfung gibt
verschiedene namen dafür das prinzip ist
dass man
sozusagen kontaktpersonen eines
infizierten
herkunft und das eben zum teil auch in
der inkubationszeit ja bis zu 21 tagen
beträgt das heißt man schützt dann auch
die kontaktperson vor dem ausbruch die
affen pokern erkrankungen hier konkret
und kann natürlich damit durch diese
doch maßnahme sehr früh auch das
infektionsgeschehen
insgesamt sommer abriegeln deswegen auch
der name war wie sein denn das ist es
das prinzip
ich sag nochmal mich herzlich bedanken
dass wir uns zur verfügung stehen als
verzögert sich offenbar immer noch die
pressekonferenz dezember für hingehört
wohl erst gegen 12 uhr 40 toll dass wir
sie haben und dass sie uns die fragen in
dieser beharrlichkeit dann auch
beantworten das hat jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen sprechstunden charakter aber
das ist natürlich super wenn wir das mit
ihnen machen können adm fragt uns darf
ich mal fragen warum wird jetzt so sehr
darauf geguckt offen pocken sind doch
nicht neu ich finde das mit dem was ich
weiß sehr überzogen hat sie recht ist es
überzogen
sommer so es geht natürlich in der
infektiologie so ein bisschen der punkt
wäre den anfängen und was halt neu ist
wir hatten
bisher bis jahr 20 28 19 ein fall in
großbritannien ein fall den usa ein fall
in israel hatten wir noch nie die affen
wochen sich mal auf dem europäischen
festland
und wir haben jetzt doch haben einen
begrenzten aber doch einen ausbruch mit
mit ungefähr 100 personen und wenn wir
eines gelernt haben aus den zeiten
dass man die dinge auch wenn sie sehr
sehr klein am anfang sind und erscheinen
ernst nehmen sollte und ich finde ja
nichts besser als wenn wir ja
hoffentlich in wenigen wochen sagen das
war's mit den affen brocken aber meine
überzeugung nach muss man jetzt eben
entscheiden entschieden handeln und das
auch in großbritannien gemacht wird also
die regel regelungs impfung solche
maßnahmen halte ich durchaus für
angebracht für risikogruppen es ist wie
gesagt keine gefahr aus meiner sicht für
die allgemeinbevölkerung und da soll
auch keine panik gemacht werden jetzt
haben sie den ersten patienten in
deutschland behandelt beziehungsweise
behandeln ihn noch ist noch stationär
bei ihnen untergebracht vielleicht auch
da doch mal die frage wie geht es ihm ja
ja das ist ein junger mann mitte 20 der
initial ein bisschen viele hatte und
dann weil er eben auch eine läsion im
rachen hatte ein wenig
schluckbeschwerden und dann eben diese
typischen hautveränderungen die juckt
das muss man sagen das hat ihnen so ein
bisschen gestört und dann noch zum arzt
geführt ich kann ihnen sagen dass dieser
patient was das thema angeht die
schluckstörung angeht keine symptomatik
mehr hat das ist sehr gut die
hauptmissionen sind zumindest ablassen
das ist auch schon mal ein gutes zeichen
und das ist solch ein typischer
patienten bugatti frage stellen müssen
wir den überhaupt stationär behandeln
kann so ein patient nicht auch im
häuslichen umfeld isoliert werden damit
auch sage ich mal den stationären sektor
nicht belastend für ein patient ist hier
auch unangenehmen im krankenhaus zu
liegen der hat auch was besseres zu tun
und das sind die fragen die wir uns
einstellen müssen wir haben muss denn
wirklich dazu den isoliert werden wo ist
die häusliche isolation sind wohl was
machen wir mit kontaktpersonen ist der
häusliche quarantäne nicht ausreichen
muss jeder in quarantäne
das sind die brennenden fragen die wir
natürlich auch heute von herrn wähler ab
antwortet haben möchten in der tat auf
diese antworten warten wir gegen 12.40
so war der letzte stand soll ist da los
gehen mit der pressekonferenz wie es die
weltgesundheitsorganisation die whu hat
die ihrer meinung nach von anfang an
sensibel genug auf dieses thema reagiert
ist man jetzt sensibler geworden sie
galten glaube ich als einer der ersten
der da auch gewarnt hat vor diesem
phänomen jetzt ja es ist so dass auch
die who durch die korona pandemie
vorsichtiger geworden ist dinge auch
sehr früh ganz nimmt in diesem fall tut
sie das auch es ist so dass wir quasi
der im anschluss an ihre sendung mit der
eu zusammenkommen weltweit schalten sich
sozusagen ärzte zu und auch das wird zu
diskutieren sein
wie man eben umgeht mit den affen
brocken aus einer globalen sicht nicht
es ist wie gesagt noch
längst nicht an die dimension erreicht
wie sie von corona kennengelernt haben
aber auch die video hat das thema klar
auf der agenda und man tauscht sich aus
und
genau die erfahrungen die jeder einzelne
in den ländern gemacht hat wir lieben
auch in so einem forum dann geteilt
warum ist eigentlich die inkubationszeit
so vergleichsweise lang also jetzt im
vergleich jetzt zug ohne
ja es ist natürlich so dass es
dauert bis sozusagen auch die
erkrankungen sich insgesamt manifestiert
bis sozusagen die hautläsionen auch
auftreten
und
wir wissen die dekorations liegt bis zu
21 tagen das ist sechs bis 21 tage ist
das wirklich
so können wir es auch im übrigen von den
klassischen hocken und
dann muss man eben sagen auch die
infektions gefährdung legte zwischen
drei und vier wochen man kann eben auch
über die pocken die relative sagt wenn
sie möchten der resistenz sind sich auch
noch infizieren zum beispiel auch über
die haut kosten deswegen ist es auch
wichtig das vielleicht so aus der praxis
dass man
die kleidung eines infizierten
entsprechend wechselt entsorgt auch die
bettwäsche ist ein thema man kann sich
also über die kosten in der bettwäsche
auch infizieren und aus klinischer sicht
ist es üblich dass man auch die kosten
abdeckt also zwischen mit sing passte
werden die patienten eingeschmiert so
dass sie sich selbst nicht über die
pocken dass sie zusagen die wären nicht
verschleppen auf der eigenen haut jetzt
haben ja noch ein wort gelernt aus der
medizin im zusammenhang mit corona
zoonosen affen brocken sind wir dass
letztlich auch wie corona eben kann man
sagen dass es davon immer mehr gibt und
wenn ja warum und vielleicht erklären
sie den begriff auch einmal kurz
ja also zur noten sind natürlich
infektionserkrankung die primär im
tierreich
kursieren brauche die sozusagen dann die
wirte sind nicht wo sich diese viren in
den tieren vermehren können und da gab
es halt immer wieder sagen ein über
sprung von von tier zu mensch
und sie stellen die richtige frage
natürlich fällt schon auf dass wir mit
eigentlich klassischen zoonosen die
plötzlich als mensch zu mensch
übertragung des ketten dann sichtbar
werden vermehrt zu tun haben jeder mal
an märz
2013 12 13 gab es ja auch die vier fälle
woran liegt das das könnte daran liegen
dass natürlich auch lebensräume
nicht zuletzt auch in tropischen
regionen dieser welt sozusagen verknappt
werden durch
brandrodungen etc das heißt mensch und
tier rücken logischerweise näher
zusammen und damit ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines einer eines
sprunges vom menschen vom tier zu mensch
eben auch sehr viel wahrscheinlicher und
deswegen haben wir wenn sie wollen
zoonosen auch im menschlichen bereich
und das wird eine entwicklung sein zum
schluss wo wir dann auch über dinge wie
klimaschutz reden müssen was man größer
denken muss nicht immer an sonst haben
wir in den nächsten jahren mal wieder
damit zu tun ja in der tat also das ist
ein ganz großes und komplexes thema wir
wollen gerade noch mal schauen auf die
situation vor ort das ist nicht in
berlin in bremen wenn ich informiert bin
beim bundes ärztetag da soll es dann
eben gleich diese pressekonferenz geben
und wir sehen immerhin schon mal eine
tür naja durch die dann gleich
geschritten werden soll vom
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach von lkw chef lothar wieler
und ärzte präsident klaus reinhardt ja
wir geben zu mit der tür alleine können
wir noch nicht viel anfangen aber die
personen kommen dann hoffentlich eben
bald durch genau diese wir haben noch
eine youtube fr geschah warum war es
möglich in deutschland die pocken
auszurotten und warum funktioniert es in
afrika nicht
ja das ist natürlich ein
sensibles thema das wir
in der westlichen welt auch sehr
stringente impfkampagnen hatten die
kampagnen sind weltweit nicht überall so
geglückt und
muss auch kritisch sagen
man hat vielleicht in der westlichen
welt auch einen blick auf
afrika gehabt nach dem motto das sind
infektionserkrankungen die berühren uns
vielleicht gar nicht das ist eine viel
eine fehleinschätzung
man wird infektionserkrankung nur durch
globale kampagnen auch bekämpfen können
das haben wir auch im kontext von corona
immer wieder gesagt es sich nicht wenn
wir drei und vier und fünf kämpfen in
deutschland einführen wir müssen auch
impfkampagnen in ärmeren ländern
ermöglichen und das mitfinanzieren zum
schluss wird uns das sonst wieder vor
die füße fallen aber das gilt ja
zuständig auch um die menschen in
ärmeren teilen dieser welt
die fragen sie müssen entschuldigen
wiederholen sich teilweise wir haben
viele zuschriften die sich eben auch mit
corona und eben dem vergleich sozusagen
beschäftigen lemmy tour fragt uns über
facebook ist es denn gefährlich wie
cobit im moment würde die antwort lauten
nein denke ich habe vielleicht kann es
noch ein bisschen aus schmücken dürfen
die digitalen es ist so dass die
infektionsketten jahren sehr viel
eingeschränkter sind der übertragungsweg
hatten mir gesagt keine rolle weil
corona hat es gereicht wenn einer im
raum hustet dann war ein risiko doch für
einen redlichen teil
sozusagen der mitmenschen in dem raum da
dass ich an qualifizieren das ist
brauchen wochen nicht der fall man weiß
auch selbst bei direktem engen
körperlichen kontakt mit einem
infizierten
van zon von zehn personen infiziert sich
nur eine person also das heißt das ist
dann auch der
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung und wir
kennen auch nur sehr beschränkt wirklich
geschlossene infektionsketten als
übertragung von mehreren menschen
hintereinander was hafenbecken angeht
maccarone ist es ja fast schon klassiker
dass man erinnert sich an den ersten
fall den webasto fall wo es ja gleich
quasi ein fast ein kleines unternehmen
getroffen hat welches hiervon tangiert
aber ja wir hatten uns für hin schon
angesprochen belgien hat bereits eine 21
tägige quarantänezeit eingeführt für
infizierte das klingt doch sehr lang
halten sie das für sinnvoll und es steht
dass im zusammenhang mit dieser doch
auch vergleichsweise lange
inkubationszeit
also zunächst müssen wir nochmal die
begriffe schärfen also für infizierte
sollte man immer von isolation sprechen
nicht von quarantäne
genau das ist für die zuhörer klar rüber
kommt garantie bezieht sich immer auf
kontaktpersonen die noch nicht als
infiziert geld ja nicht dass wir
sozusagen die klare definition also
belgien hat eine 21 tägigen isolation
meines wissens eingeführt für infizierte
das macht durchaus sinn weil wir wissen
aus von den affen pocken zumindest aus
dem afrikanischen
kontinent das ist ja der
erfahrungshorizont
personifizierten drei bis vier wochen
infektiös sind und damit haben sie
natürlich eine gewisse sicherheit wenn
sie einen patienten nach 21 tagen
entlassen dass er nicht zu hause in
seinem häuslichen umfeld andere personen
an steckt also das macht durchaus sinn
verstehe gut als wir merken uns dann
nochmal isolation von 21 tagen sehr
richtig wie ist es mit kontaktpersonen
kann man da ähnliche regeln aufstellen
wie im zusammenhang mit grüner
also bei kontaktpersonen
muss man natürlich unterscheiden was
sind das für kontaktpersonen ist ja auch
schon diskussionen letzte woche mit dem
robert-koch-institut darüber im kreis
der ja der starcookers sind zentren die
für hoch konnte diese erkrankungen
zuständig sind wobei ich die affen nicht
bürocontainers heute
aber hier hat man gesagt es gibt
quarantäne personen der klasse 1 also
die wirklich diesen engen körperkontakt
haben aber darüber hinaus gibt es auch
kontaktpersonen der gruppe 2 die
vielleicht nur im in selm urfeld leben
ohne jetzt körperlichen kontakt zu haben
also man sieht man differenziert ähnlich
wie wir das bei coronel kennengelernt
haben aber ich gehe davon aus dass wegen
nicht zu strenge regeln haben wir das
zumindest zu beginn auch der korona
panini hatte weil es eben nicht
kontaktiert es ist nicht so ansteckend
gut cola erbse in spe fragt uns wenn so
wenig menschen die affen pocken haben
wieso kann man das nicht eindämmen das
dürfte doch dann kein problem sein
eine gute frage wir hatten das schon so
ein bisschen gestreifte prinzipiell gebe
es einen sehr guten impfstoff wir hatten
über die regel durch impfung gesprochen
nur dieser impfstoff ist auf dem
deutschen markt so nicht frei verfügbar
das heißt er muss erst verfügbar gemacht
werden und da wäre es natürlich gut wenn
wir eine klare empfehlung auch dass lkws
haben aber auch nicht zuletzt das trikot
der ständigen impfkommission die hier
sozusagen auch eine gewisse
rechtssicherheit für so eine maßnahme
schafft es soll ja ein angebot seien
keine verpflichtung und das eben auch
nur für risikogruppen aber wenn das wenn
das quasi greifen würde dann hätte man
es in der tat in der hand auch sehr früh
das thema affen pocken abzuhaken ja er
hat professor rentner jetzt sehe ich
gerade einen anderen professor nämlich
ein villa durch die tür schreiten er
setzt sich allerdings erst mal ins
publikum interessanter weise ich gucke
gerade trotzdem noch mal wie es dort
jetzt weitergeht ob wir schon direkt
nach bremen gehen können wir warten doch
noch
professor rentner ist mir jetzt passiert
auch nochmal mit etwa sie bekommen den
großen ausdauer preis von uns dass sie
gesagt uns zur verfügung stehen wir
hatten eigentlich gedacht das geht nach
einer viertelstunde los und wir könnten
dann danach noch mal mit ihnen sprechen
jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen zeit
überbrücken herr villa sitzt wie gesagt
im auditorium und der bundesminister ist
auch noch nicht zu sehen wie gesagt die
fragen
sind natürlich liegen auf der hand
wiederholen sich teilweise mutationen
darüber hat man auch anfangs schon ein
bisschen gesprochen das ist natürlich
etwas was einem in zusammenhang mit
corona auch immer wieder sorgen bereitet
hat dass es da eben dann doch ja noch
mal andere qualitäten auch gibt der
übertragungswege und so weiter auch
vielleicht eine höhere gefährlichkeit
wie sehen sie das stichwort mutation im
zusammenhang mit den affen puppen
bisher muss man sagen dass es nun zwei
varianten gibt der hafen pocken die
westafrikanische mutante wenn sie so
möchten
diese ist milder die ist auch bei 1 mehr
bekannten fällen auch nachgewiesen
worden dass konkret auch bei unserem
münchner fall das hat professor wölfe
haben institut für mikrobiologie der
bundeswehr durchgeführte analyse und
dann gibt es die kombi-variante die ist
sozusagen gefährlich ja aber die ist bis
dato in diesem bisherigen kleinen
ausbruch nicht gesehen worden und
darüber hinaus lässt sich ja die frage
des zuschauers sind die zuschauerin ist
die wahl poppes kleinere veränderungen
gibt also varianten innerhalb dieser
geruch beiden großen varianten dafür
gibt es nach jetzigem wissenstand noch
keine hinweise
selbstverständlich werden auch die
genome dieser virus isolate voll durch
sequenziert wir sprechen auch von next
generation sequencing ngs abgekürzt auch
diese arbeit wird hier von einem
zertifizierten pocken labor nämlich der
bundeswehr eine professor wölfl hatte
ich genannt durchgeführt so dass wir da
auch eine sehr hohe sicherheit haben ob
es veränderungen in dem virus gibt und
man kann davon ausgehen dass auch die
berliner fälle genauso von der charité
von den kollegen am helker durch
sequenziert werden
gut
kathrin bartelt fragt uns über facebook
wie lange dauert es bis eine reguläre
pockenimpfung die wirksamkeit verliert
wir gehen davon aus dass eine reguläre
pockenimpfung eigentlich eine
lebenslange immunität beschwert es gibt
keine hinweise dass hier
eine nachlassende immunität auszugehen
ist natürlich haben wir dadurch dass die
pocken offizieller ist als ausgerottet
gelten keinen sag ich mal richtig
klinischen kann die klinische evidenz
war die exposition bisher natürlich dann
fehlt ja auch
aber wir gehen auch bezüglich der affen
brocken wie gesagt davon aus dass die
opern impfung die klassische
pockenimpfung visier bis 1980
durchgeführt wurde auch ausreichend
lebenslang schützt das ist schon mal
beruhigend so ich gucke nochmal auf die
tür und sehe betrieb ich sehe allerdings
noch keinen professor lauterbach der
fehlt noch professor wieder ist da der
sitzt allerdings in der ersten reihe im
publikum mit seinem handy und ja also
offenbar dauert ist da immer noch ein
ganz klein wenig bis es dann losgeht ich
hoffe das ist dann in wenigen minuten
tatsächlich der fall
professor wenden wer sollte wenn wir
jetzt gerade über impfungen sprechen
pockenimpfung wenn die denn dann
überhaupt wieder verfügbar ist wer
sollte diese zuerst bekommen gibt es da
so eine art priorisierung die ihnen
schon unmittelbar im kopf ist in diesem
zusammenhang
richtig die entscheidung wird zum
schluss natürlich das rkw zusammen wie
das deko treffen aber man könnte sich
vorstellen dass
insbesondere personen die eben der msm
community zu zeichnen sind also männer
die sex mit männern haben und
wissentlich einen kontakt hatte
vielleicht auch einen ungeschützten
kontakt
hatten hier natürlich mit diesem angebot
kontaktiert werden oder sich melden
können an entsprechen stellen es gibt
darüber hinaus personen mit
eingeschränkten immunsystem also
immunsupprimierten das wie gesagt kann
ein hiv patient sein der seine
medikation aus welchen gründen auch
immer nicht regelmäßig genommen hat da
ein problem hat das sind so die ersten
kandidaten die wir für so eine regel in
führung sozusagen uns vorstellen können
jetzt habe ich die information noch
vorlegen dass es einen sozusagen
planspiel gab es für den ernstfall auch
zu den affen brocken also man weiß ja
balkone oder zumindest bei einer mit
corona vergleichbaren virus verbreitung
da gab es überlegungen im vorfeld wie
man dieser sache herr werden könnte wie
ist das bei den affen brocken gibt es da
auch vergleichbare szenarien die schon
mal irgendwie durchgespielt worden sind
nein also waffen brocken hatte man im
prinzip immer quasi das auge auf afrika
gerichtet
das war aus europäischer sicht eine
erkrankung die sich im afrikanischen
kontinent abspielte und man hat
sozusagen bisher immer hafen wochen mit
einer reise anamnese nach afrika
assoziiert also bei reiserückkehrern im
zweifel noch drauf geguckt aber sonst
war das eine erkrankung die ja quasi nie
eingetragen wurde nach europa und
insofern in dem planspiel gar nicht
vorkamen recht das muss man muss man
klar sagen also das ist quasi mit harten
worten nicht einmal durchgespielt worden
jetzt habe ich hier von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
bin mal auf die seite gegangen noch die
eine oder andere information vielleicht
die ganz interessant sein könnte da
wurde auch in tabellenform ein bisschen
was dargestellt wo es also schon
bestätigte bzw verdachtsfälle gab
allerdings der zeitraum 13 bis 21 mai
also nicht mehr ganz aktuell inzwischen
sind die zahlen da natürlich noch ein
bisschen hoch gegangen aber wir sehen
hier schon dass es in portugal spanien
einige bestätigte fälle gab und eben
auch in großbritannien das sind
inzwischen ein paar mehr wir waren jetzt
bei 57 werde ich mich richtig erinnere
auch das ist hier noch mal auf der karte
dargestellt da ist jetzt afrika
interessanterweise ganz weiß das müsste
man jetzt noch mal genau gucken okay wie
das zu verstehen ist also europa kanada
nordamerika sagen wir mal in australien
hat eben schon einige fälle bestätigt
also da muss man ja dann doch sagen das
hat ja schon dann eine gewisse
verbreitung mit sich gebracht bzw diese
gefunden
muss das irgendwie anlass zur sorge
geben das ist jetzt doch irgendwo naja
muss man sagen weltweit fälle ok dann
sparen wir uns diese antwort bitte auch
für nachher und der professor der
bundesgesundheitsminister professor ist
auch aber karl lauterbach nimmt platz
und dann können wir abgeben zur
pressekonferenz und sprechen danach
nochmal weiter mit unserem experten bis
dann
so liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herzlich willkommen zur pressekonferenz
am rande des deutschen ärztetages
die konstellation kennen sie aus einem
anderen zusammenhang der ort ist dann
eher ungewöhnlich vielen dank
ärztepräsidenten reinert dass wir die
möglichkeit haben hier zum thema affen
brocken zu ihnen zu reden herr
lauterbach sie haben das wort herr weber
dann und herein hat
sehr geehrte damen und herren aus der
aktuellen pandemie haben wir gelernt
dass
transparenz hilft missverständnisse zu
vermeiden
deswegen haben wir uns entschlossen so
schnell wie möglich mit dem rk ii vor
die presse zu treten
ich bin auch erste präsident rainer hat
sehr dankbar dass er sich heute in
bremen dazu gesät und auch stellung
nehmen wird so dass wir zunächst ein
paar missverständnisse ausräumen können
und dann auch ihren fragen begegnen
können zunächst das missverständnis
nummer eins was wir mit den affen
brocken gerade erleben ist nicht der
beginn einer neuen pandemie von allem
was wir wissen
hat es ausbrüche dieser viruserkrankung
schon sehr häufig gegeben und sie kann
durch gute kontakte nach verfolgung und
vorsicht auch gut in den griff bekommen
werden somit also sind wir hier nicht am
vorabend einer neuen pandemie sondern
wir haben es hier mit ausbrüchen zu tun
die an bekannten erreger betreffen und
wo wir wissen wie wir diesen erreger
bekämpfen können im wesentlichen mit
sogenannten public es maßnahmen die
gleiche ausgeführt werden das müsste ich
dann ist nummer zwei ist dass man ja von
pocken drum nicht wirklich ernst nehmen
muss dass es auch falsch denn wir wissen
jetzt noch nicht weshalb die ausbrüche
international diesmal so anders
verlaufen als in der vergangenheit das
hier ist es möglich
dass entweder der erreger sich verändert
hat oder dass die also
anfälligkeit der menschen sich für den
erreger verändert hat und es gibt auch
noch andere möglichkeiten somit also ist
hier unsere aufgabe die dass wir die
ausbrüche früh eindämmen denn wenn wir
die ausbrüche früh ein denn dann haben
wir noch die möglichkeit zu erreichen
dass sich diese erreger nicht im beim
menschen einnistet und wir somit an
endemische sun nennenswertes indem ich
es geschehen aufbauen daher also muss
man schnell reagieren und das
missverständnis nummer drei ist dass es
nur diejenigen betreffen würde die
ungeschützten sex mit unbekannten hatten
das stimmt zwar für bestimmte
homosexuelle männer beispielsweise
sexarbeiter dass die jetzt im moment
stärker betroffen sind aber der erreger
kann auch zum beispiel kinder betreffen
er kann wie alle geschäfte betreffen er
kann kinder erwachsene jugendliche
betreffen und wir wissen das in
zentralafrika die variante dort also
üblich ist dass diese sogar eine
sterblichkeit von bis zu elf prozent bei
kindern unter 16 jahren haben kann somit
muss man das ganze schon ernst nehmen
und wir müssen reagieren
zu einem zeitpunkt wo die fahrzeuge noch
niedrig ist der wichtigste schritt dafür
ist information wir müssen uns zunächst
einmal die risikogruppen die wir derzeit
können gezielt ansprechen diese risi die
hauptrisikogruppe zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
sind männer die unter sex mit anderen
männern gehabt haben
und das muss man ansprechen können um
diese gruppe zu schützen zum eigenen
schutz der gruppe das ist keine
stigmatisierung hier handelt es sich
lediglich um die beschreibung der
derzeitigen risikogruppe und auch diese
risikogruppe kann ich ja nur schützen
und indem ich die risikogruppe auch
ansprechen direkt anspreche
vorurteilsfrei ohne stigmatisierung und
ich habe ja schon darauf hingewiesen
dass kann auch ganz anderer gruppen in
zukunft betreffen so dass wir neue
risikogruppen dann hätten das wollen wir
aber da verhindern deshalb müssen wir
reagieren war der reaktion gilt das
gesetz was auch jetzt in genf bei der
weltgesundheitsversammlung noch einmal
diskutiert wurde in den frühen phasen
einer
epidemie muss hart und früher reagiert
werden daher haben wir mit den ländern
heute eine empfehlung
entwickelt die wir den ländern für die
umsetzung ans herz legen wollen
kernbestandteil ist dass diejenigen die
infiziert sind sich für mindestens 21
tage isolieren sollen das soll es an
isolations anordnung geben für
mindestens 21 tage und also
symptomfreiheit weil wir wissen manchmal
ist die infektion auch über den 21 10
tag hinaus noch möglich dann bleiben die
kosten die sich dann typischerweise
gebildet haben noch weiter ansteckend
somit also ist hier eine isolation von
mindestens 21 tage und spät und
mindestens bis zum abfahren der kosten
not werden ergeben so soll es eine
strenge empfehlung eine dringende
empfehlung für die
kontaktpersonen geben die unmittelbaren
kontaktpersonen und der wähler wird
gleich aus führen wir das genau ist für
ebenfalls 21 tage so dass wir mit
isolation und quarantäne von mindestens
21 tage das frühe aus groß geschehen in
den griff bekommen können darüber hinaus
wollen wir auch also den schutz aufbauen
für die bevölkerung falls das geschehen
der exo sich weiter ausbreitet wollen
wir vorbereitet sein auf mögliche zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht also
empfohlen aber möglich eventuell dann
notwendige ring impfungen das heißt um
den infizierten herum werden dann die
kontakte geben wir haben einen impfstoff
bestellt bis zu 40.000 dosen im vaneks
der also für die
bekämpfung der affen brocken in den
vereinigten staaten zugelassen ist und
auch in deutschland wehren können würde
diese impfstoff kann genutzt werden um
eine ansteckung zu verhindern aber auch
bei den angesteckten bereits
angesteckten den ausbruch der erkrankung
verhindern oder zumindest verzögern es
verzögern und ich rechne damit dass wir
also hier eine reserve in kürze
geliefert bekommen das ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht klar ob wir den
impfstoff so einsetzen müssen kopien zum
beispiel bei kindern als kontaktperson
einsetzen können oder müssen das wissen
wir noch nicht das wird mit dem robert
koch institut aber auch mit dem paul
ehrlich institut sehr intensiv
besprochen schließlich ich bin im
täglichen austausch auch in dieser sache
mit dem robert-koch-institut und auch
mit den kolleginnen kollegen von der
europäischen idee behörde die hier also
an rest appraisal gestern 14 uhr möglich
gemacht hat und die sich sehr intensiv
damit beschäftigt wie diese ausbrüche in
europa verhindert werden können wir sind
auch sehr eng mit dem austausch ich
glaube dass wir noch sehr gute chancen
haben diese diesen erreger zu stoppen
nicht nur in deutschland zu stoppen
sondern in ganz europa zu stoppen dafür
machen wir derzeit alles wie reagieren
hart und schnell und werden also nicht
zulassen dass hier die reaktion
verschleppt wird
herzlichen dank herr professor wieder
bitte
ok guten tag meine damen ist auch grün
werder bremen das passt ja gut also in
den letzten tagen sind einige fälle von
affen pocken aufgetreten und zwar in
einer vielzahl von ländern wie wir das
bislang noch nicht gesehen hatten
momentan der stand ist von 11 uhr heute
morgen sind uns bekannt 177 fälle in 16
ländern die mehrheit und das ist sie
besonders hat keine aktuelle reise
geschichte in ein dänisches gebiet diese
affen brocken kommen ja in
zentralafrikanischen staaten vor und in
westafrika und es handelt sich bei den
meisten fällen um männer die sex mit
männern hatten
tatsächlich ist das erste mal dass wir
infektionsketten in europa beobachten
ohne einen epidemiologischen link zu
endemischen regionen zu haben das ist
das bemerkenswerte wir haben deshalb
anfang der letzten woche die ärzteschaft
und verschiedene verbände darauf
hingewiesen dass sie achtsam sind und
patienten die symptome haben rasch zum
arzt gehen um die abklären zu lassen und
wir bringen damit auch in zusammenhang
dass nur die ersten patienten in
deutschland auch gefunden wurden und
sich aktiv bei ärzten vorgestellt haben
der erste fall war um 52 5 das war in
münchen heute der stand ist der aktuell
von einer stunde dass wir fünf fälle
bislang 1 robert koch institut
übermittelt worden es sind alle fünf
männer und drei davon gehen wir davon
aus nach dem jetzigen wissen dass sie im
ausland exponiert waren bei zwei fällen
wurde der explosionsort in deutschland
angegeben die betroffene person klagen
über symptome wie fieber sie haben
lymphknotenschwellungen im hautausschlag
hautläsionen das ist ja das typische
starke schmerzen teilweise auch im
intimbereich jugend allgemeine
krankheitszeichen auch erschöpfung
was wissen über offenburg es ist eine
seltene viruserkrankung und sie wird
vermutlich vor allen dingen von
nagetieren auf den menschen übertragen
es hat sich also um eine zoonose wieder
mal eine zoonose wie wir sie auch
erwarten etwa dreiviertel oder zwei
drittel aller krankheiten gewerbe
menschen haben sind durch torlosen
hervorgerufen also letztlich vom tier
auf den menschen übertragen wurden die
affen parken können durch einen engen
kontakt mit einer infizierten person
oder auch einem infizierten tier oder
auch durch kontaminiertes material auf
menschen übertragen werden sie werden
aufgelöst durch das affen pockenvirus
monkey box virus wird das auch in
literatur genannt oder mpx v und das ist
aus der gattung der otto aktivieren das
heißt dieses virus ist verwandt mit den
klassischen humanen pockenviren aber es
ist eben nicht das humane pockenvirus
nicht dass es hier zu missverständnissen
kommt sie sind in west und zentralafrika
vorrink bei nagetieren verbreitet und
tatsächlich wurde erstmals er vor 52
jahren 1970 in kongo in der republik
kongo in der demokratischen republik
kongo zum ersten mal wurde diese brocken
bei einem menschen nachgewiesen bei
einem neun monate alten kind wir kennen
das virus ist seit 1958 uns also auch
gar nicht so lange 2003 kam es
tatsächlich zum ersten nachweis von
affen pocken außerhalb des afrikanischen
kontinents das war damals in den
vereinigten staaten durch den import von
bestimmten ratten affen brocken sind in
der regel und das ist die gute nachricht
eine selbst limitierende krankheit von
der sich die meisten menschen innerhalb
weniger wochen erholen dennoch kann es
eben bei einigen personen auch eine
schwere erkrankung auftreten nicht der
lauterbacher nannte gerade ein paar
zahlen dazu sind leicht von menschen die
nicht leicht von mensch zu mensch zu
übertragen und deshalb schätzt dass sie
die sie dass wir haben das wochenende
gemeinsam also viele kollegen aus europa
war auch vom rk ii haben wir ein so
genanntes risk assessment erarbeitet
dass es gestern um 14 uhr auf die
website gestellt worden das easy diese
schätzt das risiko für die
allgemeinbevölkerung als gering ein das
gesamtrisiko für personen mit mehreren
sexualpartnern wird vom sed sie als
moderat eingeschätzt und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich affen
brocken bei personen mit mehreren
sexualpartnern ausbreiten die ist hoch
dass die einschätzung die sich
beim jetzigen ausbruch wurden vor allen
dingen männer diagnostiziert die sex mit
männern haben also msm aber dass auch
hatte
minister lauterbach zu recht noch mal
klar gemacht dass wir es kann natürlich
unabhängig von der sexuellen
orientierung auf jeden übertragen werden
unabhängig vom geschlecht vom alter aber
eine gefährdung für die gesundheit der
allgemeinen bevölkerung in deutschland
wird eben nach derzeitigen erkenntnissen
als gering eingeschätzt
es ist aber klar dass weitere fälle in
deutschland zu erwarten sind unser ziel
das ist deshalb den ausbruch einzudämmen
das kann eben nur gelingen wenn wir zum
einen eine erfolgreiche kontakt
nachverfolgung machen da kennen sie sich
inzwischen glaube ich alle sehr sehr gut
aus wie das funktioniert vermeiden von
engen kontakten zu infizierten personen
so viel jene maßnahmen im umgang mit
infizierten das bleibt natürlich der
beste schutz aber dafür müssen eben
diejenigen die halt unter risiko stehen
müssen darüber informiert sein sie
müssen wachsam rhein zum arzt gehen und
sich selber eben auch 18 verhalten die
inkubationszeit ist eine literatur
angaben zwischen 5 und 21 tagen daher
kommt auch diese frist von 21 tagen über
für die quarantäne empfehlen nach jetzt
im kenntnis haben sich die meisten
personen von diesen 177 auf großen
veranstaltungen angesteckt die mit
sexuellen aktivitäten verbunden waren
beim auftreten von einem ungewöhnlichen
ausschlag oder version oder wenn ein
verdacht auf affen pocken besteht
sollten eben wirklich unmittelbar
ärztliche hilfe aufgesucht werden um in
die infektionsketten zu brechen
empfiehlt das lka wenn jetzt schon
wecker gestellt hatte eine isolierung
bis zum abfall der kosten aber
mindestens von 21 tagen und für enge
kontakte empfehlen wir eine quarantäne
von 21 tagen ebenfalls
man da und herren wir befinden uns in
einem frühen sturz stadium dieses
ausbruchs und vieles ist auch noch
unbekannt aber wir beobachten die lage
weiterhin sehr genau und passe natürlich
die empfehlungen den aktuellen
wissensstand an sie finden alle
aktuellen informationen die website
glaubt gerade heute gegen 12 uhr haben
wir die einer faq auf die website
gestellt die sind immer aktualisiert
bitte gehen sie auf die website schauen
sich die infos an dankeschön
herzlichen dank der professor will herr
doktor rheinland bitte ja ich würde das
meiste dazu ist gesagt ich teile
ausdrücklich durch vorgehensweise der
minister lauterbach hier ist geziert hat
die finde ich hundertprozentig richtig
würden wir eins zu eins ähnlich und
genauso empfehlen wir werden unseren
teil in dem was die informationen des
aks angeht was insgesamt prozedere die
seitens des ministeriums angeht ist
jetzt wahrscheinlich ärzteschaft
entsprechend informieren auch anhalten
sich in diesen situationen text
einzubeziehen und entsprechend zu
handeln also auch darauf zu achten dass
achtsamkeit unklare befunde und so
weiter und so fort in diesem kontext
auch bewertet werden ich mache
vielleicht aus zwei dinge aus
medizinischer sicht aufmerksam auch
vielleicht im dialog ich glaube dies die
lange denkbar lange inkubationszeit
beiden fällen ein gewisses problem
darstellt weil hier hat der kontakt gab
hat natürlich unter umständen bis zu
drei wochen lang symptomlos sein kann
und dennoch infiziert ist und vielleicht
eben auch infektions ist das ist ja
nicht total sicher zu wissen aber
trotzdem muss man das in betracht ziehen
und insofern glaube ich muss man sich
überlegen ob man die kontakt
nachverfolgung und derjenigen die
infiziert sind im hinblick auf
vielleicht auch post explosion der
impfungen sich vorstellen kann dass das
eine odere zweite ist worauf wieder noch
einmal hinweisen möchte das aber schon
geschrieben wir wieder das ja auch in
der vergangenheit des irischen
aufgetreten ist und es bisher eigentlich
immer gelungen ist es erfolgreich
einzudämmen ist also sozusagen im umgang
mit dieser erkrankung was ihre
kontinuität übertragungsweg und auch die
möglichkeiten von isolation angeht ich
glaube weil gute chancen hat wenn man
jetzt sehr frühzeitig hat handelt dafür
zu sorgen dass es eben nicht so einen
ähnlichen situationen kommt
herzlichen dank wir kommen zu ihren
fragen wir haben leider keine mikros
hier
das kriegen wir schon hin bitte
ich glaube bei ihnen ist das ein anderes
thema da kommen wir gleich zu
keiner eine frage zum an keyboards
bitteschön
da zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist die regen
impfung nur also ein konzept es wird
nicht empfohlen wir haben sich neben dem
stoff wir besorgen den impfstoff
prophylaktisch hier geht es darum dass
man schnell handelt denn wenn die
ausbrüche
weitergehen würden dann müssen wir
natürlich unser konzept anpassen und
dann könnte an der regen impfung
tatsächlich auch eine rolle spielen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist das nicht geplant
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt arbeiten wir nun
mit den methoden die er wieder gerade
vorgetragen hat dass wir die menschen
isolieren und in quarantäne bringen das
konzept der ring impfung würde dann
beispielsweise zum tragen kommen wenn
eine person sich infiziert hat und lebt
in also einem umfeld von menschen die
besonders gefährdet sind beispielsweise
immunsupprimierten und dergleichen dann
könnte man die prophylaktisch impfen um
also zu verhindern falls sie sich
angesteckt haben dass der ausbruch also
kommt oder dass sie so schwer erkannte
die impfung dann eingesetzt aber wie
gesagt das ist ein konzept was wir es
hat nur
vorbereitende reinhardt hat es ebenfalls
gesagt wir müssen vorbereitet sein und
daher möchte ich nicht in einer
situation kommen wo wir ein solches
konzert würde es notwendig werden dann
sagen müssen wir haben lange kein
impfstoff
herr 1
man hat das stadtarchiv zahlen müssten
für das passierte nicht
also was war der erste punkt noch einmal
die zweite punkt weil
die immunität genau genau es ist davon
auszugehen dass diejenigen die also
gegen pocken also ergänzt worden sind
und da war die also impfung ja die
pflichtimpfung
ausgelaufen
noch also
in den späten siebziger jahren und also
ich glaube in der früheren ddr es bis 82
geimpft worden in dieses richtig in
erinnerung habe somit also diejenigen
die noch die impfungen damals bekommen
habe du hast du noch weniger gm vor die
durften gegen gegen pocken
sollten die eine immunität besitzen wie
ausgeprägte immunität genau ist wissen
wir nicht wahrscheinlich ist es eine
also komplette immunität mann war es das
aber noch nicht so genau diese
impfstoffe die
hocker neben dem stoff für die wir auch
lagern also aus sicherheitsgründen weil
es zum einen also
wieder ausgegeben könnte auch die
natürlichen was ist ausgestorben das
pockenvirus aber kann sein dass es also
noch reservoirs gibt nur zum zweiten
dass es auch glaube ich
2013 oder 2014 gelungen also
menschen pocken also oder für den
menschen befallen der brocken zu
produzieren in kanada in einem sehr
umstrittenen experiment daher haben wir
aus sicherheitsgründen haben wir rocken
virus gelagerte wer aber für die
bekämpfung der affen brocken nicht
geeignet weil er mit nebenwirkungen
einher gehen durfte die also viele affen
brocken
impfungen nicht vertretbar wären daher
also dieser impfstoff infanrix und
internet ist in den vereinigten staaten
zugelassen ist aber hier auch für monkey
box also geprüft worden somit die
unterlagen dafür
wären vorhanden und wir könnten diesen
impfstoff sollte es notwendig werden
unmittelbar einsetzen
ich kann das gerne noch ergänzen also
die immunität ist gegeben sie wird
natürlich immer schwächer je länger
diese impfung her ist also die konkret
ist auch einer der person
infiziert der auch eine impfung damals
hatte also die immunität lässt natürlich
nach aber die in das krankheitsgeschehen
wird abgemildert wir müssen immer vor
augen haben dass wir als war die pocken
ausgerottet haben damals unterwegs ist
eben der dass diese brocken ebenen
kreuzimmunität haben zum teil mit den
affen brocken da waren vier milliarden
menschen auf der welt ja wir sind jetzt
acht milliarden menschen das heisst also
jetzt das ist natürlich in der gesamten
population ist einfach eben kaum eine
belastbare immunität und das ist auch
der grund warum viele wissenschaftler in
den letzten jahren immer wieder unter
anderem auch davor gewarnt haben dass so
ein affe pockenvirus im sinne
immunologische lücke reinkommen aber
natürlich allergie nach 80 dann geboren
sind sowieso die können ja gar keine
immunität haben und die andere sache ist
lauter war spricht dass genau an es gibt
ja impfstoff gegen pocken der der
eingelagert ist aber wir erinnern uns
vielleicht auch noch als ich selber bin
auch noch geimpft dieser impfstoff hat
ja teilweise schon ordentliche
nebenwirkungen gehabt erinnert sich die
ärzte alle ganz gut an und darum wurde
auch das weiterentwicklung das bieten
dieses impfstoffs von dem herr
lauterbach sprach der ist eben hat
deutlich weniger nebenwirkungen das ist
ein modifiziertes ankara vakzin ja virus
das ist sehr oft passiert worden eine
zelt gut ort eine sehr sehr gute
immunität und eine geringe nebenwirkung
dass das kann man eben einsetzen dieses
die diesen impfstoff und die strategien
wie man das macht die muss man sich
überlegen und es muss eben besorgt
werden es gibt eben natürlich ist doch
klar das ging eine seltene krankheit
nicht riesige impfstoffmengen einfach
auf vorrat sind das ist muss man immer
wissen
so willkommen zu ihrer fahren
wie schön
[Musik]
es gibt
vergabestandards und diese
vergabestandards hin entwickelt worden
mit den entsprechenden
fachgesellschaften und
ist natürlich schwierig im einzelfall zu
prüfen ob also bei der anwerbung dann
diese kriterien erfüllt worden sind aber
die frage die sie mir jetzt stellen ist
abstrakt können aber gibt es einen fall
wo ist also aus ihrer sicht nicht
ausreichend gesichert war
[Musik]
dann werde ich das sofort prüfen und
dankt ihnen für den hinweis also ich
habe mit dem gesundheitsminister
von ich habe mit dem gesundheitsminister
von indonesien also noch darüber
gesprochen wie wir sicherstellen können
dass zum einen aus die quali die
qualifikationsanforderungen
eingehalten werden und wie wir auch
sicherstellen können dass menschen die
sich uns hier an vertrauen so behandelt
werden und so klar bezug auf ihre
finanzierung in bezug auf ihre
lebensumstände aber auch die
arbeitsbedingungen dass wir das in jeder
hinsicht vertreten können denn das wäre
der fall mehr zur aufmerksamkeit
gebracht wird werde ich mir das genau
anschauen
hier vorne ja soweit also die
pressekonferenz mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister mit karl
lauterbach und mit lothar wieler auf die
beiden herren will ich mich jetzt mal
kurz beschränken noch kurz
zusammenfassen eben was gesagt wurde
also herr lauterbach meinte kein beginn
einer neuen pandemie das ganze könne
durch gute kontakt nachverfolgung und
auch vorsicht daneben in den griff
bekommen werden trotzdem soll man das
ganze nicht unterschätzen ist gelte die
ausbrüche früh einzudämmen
infizierte sollten sich für 21 tage
mindestens isolieren also da folgt man
dem beispiel belgiens eine enge
kontaktperson für die gelte das dann im
grunde auch auf 21 tage eine impfstoffe
reserve 40.000 dosen sei bestellt würde
in kürze geliefert die details wer die
dann bekommt ist diese noch offen das
muss noch ausgearbeitet werden insgesamt
aber habe man gute chancen den erreger
in deutschland und dann auch in europa
in den griff zu bekommen
lothar wieler sagte noch einmal das 177
fälle bislang registriert sind in 16
ländern die meisten von männern die sex
mit männern hatten aber es wurde auch
noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass das
ganze potenzial alle bevölkerungsgruppen
betreffen könnte die meisten menschen
erholen sich zum glück vollständig auch
ohne allzu schweren verlauf das risiko
für die allgemeine bevölkerung wird als
eher gering momentan eingeschätzt fragen
auch noch mal rund um dieses thema ein
faq auf der website des rk ii auch das
vielleicht für euch noch mal interessant
wenn ihr euch dann noch mal schlauer
machen wollte aber ihr bleibt vielleicht
am besten auch noch kurz dann dran denn
wir sprechen mit weiter mit professor
clemens rentner chefarzt an der münchen
klinik schwabing schön dass sie noch bei
uns sind herr professor wenn da haben
sie jetzt überraschen dass auf dieser
bka vernommen oder alles so wie sie es
im prinzip erwartet hatten
es war so wie erwartet wie auch schon
vor diskutiert in die letzte woche in
einem längeren lkw call von den
entsprechenden zentren die auch
betroffen sind hat doch wie
gut ist dass wir jetzt eine gewisse
einem gewissen rahmen haben an dem wir
uns orientieren können als janis erwähnt
die 21 tage isolation
auch die 21-jährige quarantäne sind
details zu klären wie gehen wir mit
häuslicher isolation um liegen wir genau
mit mit der quarantäne was sind den
kontaktpersonen ist es jeder der auch
nur flüchtige kontakt hatte ich denke ja
nicht das muss natürlich aus der
ausdifferenzierten definiert werden habe
ich eine wichtige botschaft ist
zumindest das konzept der ring impfung
die jetzt auch offiziell angesprochen
wurde
40.000 dosen das ist denke ich auch ein
vernünftiger anfangen muss aber
allerdings dazu sagen
40.000 dosen
heißt 20.000 menschen die geschützt
werden weil sie müssen zweimal impfen
also noch ist der impfstoff nicht in den
händen herr lauterbach hat es ja klar
gesagt er muss quasi oder ist bestellt
worden aber wir haben ihn noch nicht
verfügbar von daher bleibt es erst mal
meinem konzept es wäre wünschenswert
wenn wir das konzept sehr schnell
umsetzen könnten weil nur dann haben wir
wirklich die schlagkräftig eindämmung
ich weise darauf hin dass die briten
bereits geringe impfung begonnen haben
ja die zahl von 40.000 dosen die sie
haben gerade auch noch mal angesprochen
da wird natürlich bei uns dann schon
gefragt roberto maldonado auf youtube
warum denn nur so wenige das ist doch
fahrlässig herr lauterbach aber sie
hatten gerade gesagt sie halten die zahl
eigentlich für angemessene moment also
es ist sozusagen bei dem jetzigen noch
begrenzten infektionsgeschehen fünft ich
muss dazu sagen
der impfstoff ist hier auch nicht
sozusagen ramos verfügbar ich hätte
darauf hingewiesen dass wir eigentlich
diesen guten im fahrgeschäft gar nicht
in öffentlichen apotheken verfügbaren er
muss jetzt also quasi produziert werden
bzw abgezwackt werden es gibt andere
länder die sich die dinge schon
reserviert haben und so von derartigen
ist ein guter start und es ist ja auch
das was wir jetzt an zahlen erwarten an
neuinfizierten wir sprechen nicht über
100.000 infizierte pro tag wie wir das
vielleicht von corona erkennen sondern
wir erwarten natürlich in den nächsten
tagen und wochen immer wieder mal neue
fälle aber sollte nicht so sprunghaft
exponentiell ansteigen das
infektionsgeschehen und von daher könnte
man auch mit 20.000 dosen man viel
erreichen gerade am anfang einer
infektionswelle der professor will hat
er auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass
die meisten fälle bislang männer sind
wiederum die sex mit männern hatten in
deutschland bislang fünf fälle hier sagt
auch alle männer und da fragt uns jetzt
über youtube für eine userin sind denn
frauen ungefährdet könnte man denken
aber dem ist glaube ich nicht so nein
dass das hat ja auch noch mal ganz klar
betont dass natürlich prinzipiell sich
jeder anstecken kann das kann auch
sozusagen die die pflegekraft sein die
einen patienten versorgt aber es kann
natürlich auch im rahmen eines innen
körper kontaktes wir hatten vorhin über
das kursverhalten gesprochen als
übertragungsweg tröpfcheninfektionen das
kann auch ein thema sein es geht
natürlich letztendlich umgesetzt
ungeschützten promiskuität
sexualkontakt insbesondere und dass das
ist natürlich dann auch über
geschlechter hinaus da kann man es
fortgetragen werden also ganz wichtig
auch von meiner seite es geht nicht um
stigmatisierung von und
bevölkerungsgruppen
das hat ja wieder auch und auch in
lauterbach sehr stark betont das ist
auch wichtig und richtig genau da
schließen wir uns an noch mal die frage
über youtube von coco wimper macht es
sinn für männer die mit männern sex
haben und vorerkrankungen haben sich
impfen zu lassen vielleicht gerade noch
einmal abschließend weil die oft kommen
zum thema impfen wer sollte sich nach
ihrer einschätzung impfen lassen wir
hatten vorher auch schon mal
angesprochen mit der priorisierung wenn
sie das vielleicht kurz zum abschluss
noch einmal zusammenfassen würden ganz
genau welche impfung sollte man zunächst
sein es gibt keine präventive
vorbeugende impfung das war die frage
des zuschauers und wenn man zwei spiele
immunsupprimierten keine kann krebs
leiden hat oder eine hiv erkrankung die
noch nicht ausreichend kontrolliert ist
wäre das eine sinnvolle maßnahmen
sozusagen geschützt sind vorher zu
kämpfen aber eben auch personen die
exponiert waren
mit einem poken infizierten das ist
sozusagen dann die sogenannte post
exposition elle impfung in der
inkubationszeit die erkrankung ist dann
noch nicht ausgebrochen bei dem bei der
kontaktperson da machte ihm vom auch
sind beides wohl ja explizit
angesprochen und für beides könnte man
den link soffin von ex auch einführen
weiter ergänzen wir haben auch einen
therapeuten kommt das würde heute nicht
erwähnt das tqw ring hat welches
natürlich auch in dem kontext nach
exposition als möglicher
als einsatzgebiet wird nutzern zu
diskutieren wäre professor clemens
rentner war das für uns chefarzt an der
münchen klinik schwabing ganz herzlichen
dank für ihre ausdauer und dass wir uns
heute so viele fragen beantworten
konnten besten dank liebe grüße nach
münchen und auch noch mal ein herzliches
dankeschön an euch natürlich liebes
publikum auch danke für die fragen und
kommentare jahr vorsicht ja panik nein
so kann man es vielleicht zusammenfassen
das ist der aktuelle wissensstand zum
thema offen pocken danke fürs dabeisein
und bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut